well here's a story for you dave portnoy
is the founder of course of barstool
sports he's a cultural icon fortnite is
not especially political he seems a lot
more interested in stock tips than
election polling but he is
unapologetically american always has
been he thinks you ought to be allowed
to say what you really think
in this country even if nbc news doesn't
like it
so that attitude and his success as a
publisher has made portney a massive
threat to legacy media organizations
they truly hate him so last week they
decided to destroy his life
a sleazy little blog called business
insider dispatched a robot reported to
snoop around in portnoy's sex life they
didn't find anything illegal or even
especially surprising but they tried
their best to humiliate him now they're
harassing his advertisers the question
is can this business insider whoever
that is succeed in killing dave portnoy
and that's a question that anyone who's
interested in free speech and the free
exchange of ideas should probably care
about to answer it we've invited dave
portnoy himself to join us tonight we're
grateful that he has dave thanks so much
for coming on so so the i guess the
rules are
they don't like your posture the cut of
your jib your attitude you don't take
orders so they send some little robot to
snoop around in your personal life don't
find anything illegal but print all this
stuff anonymously about your sex life
and then try to destroy you like these
are the rules now
seems that eight months so i've heard
about this uh article this hit piece
that they had in the works for eight
months i'm talking everybody that was
attached to me on social media people i
didn't even know people who talked about
me every single person attached me this
reporter reached out and basically had
leading questions hey any dirt on dave
porter anything bad to find they found
virtually nothing two examples i'd argue
both which i have unequivocally provided
proof that they're not telling the truth
beyond that not only me there's one
instance there's an actual police report
that reads like it's from the onion i'm
basically accused of going to a local
cookie shop
with a different girl every few days so
that is the gist of it how they are
allowed to publish this and they couch
it in a very i guess i guess smart for
them they never accuse me of anything if
they just lead you to water and want you
to drink with sensationalistic headlines
that if i read about myself not knowing
me like oh this is a bad guy if you dig
into it there's absolutely nothing there
they reach out to their average our
advertisers as you say and said hey are
you advertising with dave because we're
going to write an article about how bad
he is what's the proof our own article
i've offered them the chance to discuss
it with me with their own cameras their
own recorders as many people as they
want to have a discussion so we can go
back and forth i could say hey these
facts directly dispute what you wrote
they won't do it they said don't talk to
us they won't even discuss it they print
and run they print and run it's
disgusting and it's character
assassination my lawyers have said just
let it go it'll go away i'm not going to
let it go because this is this behavior
i've never been attacked like this i've
been attacked for two decades but never
escalated to this length and frankly
it's scary i didn't know that you could
do this
so it's interesting there are a lot of
interesting things here but you know
business insider was founded by a guy
who pled to securities fraud and
admitted lying to investors which i you
know so it's like i don't know maybe
don't throw stones but this is a
publication supposed to be covering
business you run a business you've been
really successful in business you got to
kind of wonder why you you're not
running for anything like is there a
business angle do you think in their
decision to try and destroy you
it's weird because i'm being treated as
though i'm a politician in politics is
the dirtiest game ever i will say uh
penn which is a pen national which is
involved with bar stool there's a lot of
penn stock penn stock had their earnings
the day this article dropped the day
this article dropped there's 365 days in
a year it dropped the same day the day
before there was wild shorting basically
people betting against penn you can bet
on a stalk against it for some reason
tons of people bet against it the day
before it dropped as you mentioned henry
blodgett was convicted for sec fraud he
can never trade stocks the rest of his
life he stole working people's money
that's the ceo of the company that wrote
this hit piece
it's just unbelievable i mean from my
perspective not involved in your
business or any of this stuff
it's just important that people say what
they really mean and that we have space
for someone who's unapologetically
honest
and maybe not feminized and so i just am
really rooting for you to survive this
and i know that you will dave portnoy
thank you for coming on thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else